bon ça vous saviez que ce chocolat à
plus d'un million et demi de followers
sur un style
un fan club digne des plus grands
joueurs de foot
même les admirateurs capable de passer
douze heures dehors pour être les
premiers à le déguster au petit matin
quatre rôles pains au chocolat chapeau
belle opération marketing
enfin même temps il faut dire qu'il est
très bon alors bienvenue en 2020
bienvenue dans la bulle du clean air un
monde où les cuisiniers et les
pâtissiers sont les rock stars d'une
nouvelle génération où les marques
alimentaires sont aussi identitaire que
nike et adidas dans les années 80 cette
génération c'est aussi celle d'un
engagement écologique
derrière la sobriété heureuse de pierre
rabhi c'est la permaculture avec maxime
de rostolan le zéro déchet de bea
johnson et même l'aiment pas vraiment
écocitoyen de julien vidal alors une
génération résolument engagés pour
l'écologie n'est ce pas pendant ce
temps-là 30% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre sont liés à notre
alimentation de la fourche à la
fourchette c'est 30 % de nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de serre alors
ce soir je m'adresse à vous et je
m'adresse aussi aux producteurs aux
restaurateurs aux territoires pour
qu'ensemble on essaye de commencer à
réfléchir à un système alimentaire plus
vertueux et puis à mon échelle à un
marketing alimentaire plus vertueux
parce que le meilleur marketing
culinaire c'est celui qui n'existe pas
ça tombe bien ou plutôt mal en
l'occurrence parce que cet été j'ai
publié un livre sur le grand livre du
marketing culinaire c'est toute ma vie
courte certes mais toute ma vie le
marketing culinaire alors pourquoi parce
que j'ai eu la chance de naître dans un
restaurant écologique centenaire et du
coup quand j'étais petit mon occupation
favori c'était de regarder les
cuisiniers s'affairent en cuisine de
côté les petits pois à mes heures
perdues au printemps et puis parfois
d'aller humer la douce odeur du pain
perdu qui cuit dans le four
ensuite j'ai fait des études en sciences
pour en arts appliqués et puis j'ai
soutenu une thèse de doctorat qui
portait sur rire d'autres que le
marketing culinaire vous l'aurez compris
alors je vis je dors comme je mange
voilà
je me marre gens que je suis c'est ce
qu'on dit du coup j'ai épousé un homme
qui s'avère être cuisinier et qui est
adapté de cuisine sauvage et puis j'ai
deux enfants alors là vous dites a
commencé à s'égarer c'est un peu un
discret tout ça mais en fait c'est pas
anodin comme information quand on sait
que les jeunes foyers commencent leur
transition écologique souvent à la
naissance du premier enfant
justement à travers l'alimentation enfin
moi retournons à notre sujet le meilleur
marquer titulaire culinaire c'est celui
qui n'existe pas mais pour commencer à
retourner aux basiques ou pour révéler
l'inconnu ou le connu vous avez compris
le lien avec le sujet de ce soir
il faut comprendre pourquoi on en est
arrivé là
pourquoi est-ce qu'on est au système
alimentaire actuelle parce qu'au départ
finalement à manger tous locale et tous
bio la question se posait pas n'est ce
pas mais à la sortie la seconde guerre
mondiale il a fallu dans une robe
exemple relancer une économie
il a fallu redynamiser des campagnes
donner à manger à des familles décimées
alors il fallait produire vite et
beaucoup force était donc de lancer une
agriculture intensive et les objectifs
ont été atteints
au départ pas de marketing tout ce qui
était produit était acheté tout ce qui
était achetée était moins manger et puis
à mesure de la construction de ce marché
on est arrivé à une saturation de
l'offre qui fait qu'on est passé d'un
marketing de la demande
répondre aux besoins des consommateurs
un marketing de l'offre mieux vendre et
créer de nouveaux besoins
en parallèle de cette construction
l'industrie alimentaire
on a découvert les premières crises
alimentaires les premiers scandales
sanitaires
vous avez tous entendu parler de la
maladie de la vache folle rossfeld jacob
vous avez tous vécu je pense le scandale
de la fameuse viande de cheval dans les
lasagnes et plus récemment le lait
infantile français contaminés en 2017
alors ces crises alimentaires elles ont
induit une situation de gastronomie ce
sont ces crises alimentaires associé à
une individualisation de la société qui
nous amène à une situation de
gastronomie alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ce mot à parfaire intelligent
gastro pour l'alimentation anomie pour
la perte de repères en gros on sait plus
quoi manger avec qui comment pourquoi
et là c'était une super est parti unité
pour le marketing à l'époque il n'y
avait pas de marketing il fallait juste
que le produit soit disponible et puis
ensuite on est passé au prix le plus bas
la meilleure qualité le plus joli
emballage la plus belle histoire la plus
belle expérience est aujourd'hui la plus
grande éthique
cette quête d'authenticité elle pose
question dans un moment si consumériste
si bien qu' il ya un ouvrage que je
voudrais vous recommander de
jean-laurent cassely no fake contre
histoire dans notre quête d'authenticité
est aussi sorti cet été
et dans cet ouvrage il nous sommes trois
exemples de ce marketing de
l'authenticité culinaire tout d'abord
ses coffee shops tellement parisien au
parement de brique finalement très
propre hymne ou alors un néo routier en
plein coeur du marais parisien où on se
déplace plutôt à vélo et en trottinette
électrique quand camions et finalement
le restaurant d'un chef de télé réalité
qui servent sur le marketing
intergénérationnel elle nous propose un
restaurant juif très judicieusement
appelé mammy alors pourquoi ça marche le
marketing de l'authenticité
parce que grâce à cette situation de
gastronomie on est devenus de plus en
plus mais aux folles encore un grand mot
néo fob c'est cette peur de l'inconnu
dans paradise oliver en fait claude
fischer nous révèle le fait qu'on a tous
un peu d'appétence pour la nouveauté
l'année au filet et toute une peur de
l'inconnu la néophobie et en fonction de
nos jeunes deux âges des situations
humaines de la saison on va faire
évoluer les curseurs là en hiver vous
avez dû voir plein de photos hashtag
team raclette
on veut la comfort food on veut du bon
du gras et puis en été on va être un peu
plus créatifs ont voyagé on sera content
de déguster des cocktails aux saveurs
exotiques etc
c'est aussi pourquoi en bretagne on
mange des huîtres mais certainement pas
des insectes
expliquez moi la différence un autre
concept de social de socio anthropologie
alimentaire introduit par claude fischer
c'est la notion de pensée magique qui
est directement associé à la notion de
principe d'incorporation cette pensée
magique elle a un impact sur le
symbolisme en marketing je vous ai
toujours pas dit ce que ça voulait dire
la pensée magique
c'est lié par exemple locaux cannibale
alors les cannibales ils mangeaient la
cervelle de leurs ennemis ils buvaient
leur sang pour s'emparer de leur
intelligence ou de leurs forces
vos parents et doit vous embêter même si
vous avez tendance à être végétarien
quand vous êtes un peu faible à n'en
manger du boudin noir ou la viande rouge
ça va vous donner les forces et puis je
suis sûr qu'il y en a certains dans la
salle qu'on passait tout le mois de
janvier à boire du thé vert pour se
sentir plus légers après les excès des
fautes défaite est sévère c'est mieux si
les bouillonnants un pas pourquoi c'est
mieux ici les bio parce que heureusement
il ya des gens qui ont travaillé à avoir
mois avant nous et qui en effet défendu
une alimentation durable émis d'énormes
sur sarah
le problème c'est que toute la
communication et le marketing sur
l'alimentation durable il a commencé par
le bon pour soi le bon pour soi c'est
certes pas d'additif pas de pesticides
faible en calories des produits avec des
arguments nutritionnelle de qualité dans
l'alimentation du real c'est comme dans
développement durable ya trois piliers
l'écologique l'économique et le social
ben le pardon l'alimentation durable
c'est bon pour soi bon pour la société
est bon pour l'environnement
je voulais quand même reversé ceux qui
travaillent depuis toujours parce qu'il
ya toujours eu des restaurateurs qui
faisait dire leur métier toujours des
producteurs qui ont bien fait leur
métier aussi
et aussi des restaurateurs qui sont les
porte-paroles toute une génération et
des générations précédentes comme alain
ducasse ou olivier au large et qu'on
écrit des ouvrages connu sur le sujet il
ya d'autres restaurateurs qui sont
connus pour leur travail sur
l'alimentation sociale je pense à
massimo bottura avec leurs effets torrio
ou avec plus récemment les cafés joyeux
merci pour ce que vous faites et merci
d'entraîner toute une économie
agroalimentaire avec vous parce que oui
les restaurateurs ont un rôle
ils ont même une responsabilité parce
qu'ils vont impacter les producteurs ils
vont impacter les autres restaurateurs
qui suivent leur exemple et you même
impact et leurs clients d'ailleurs c'est
à ce titre que j'ai eu la chance de
recevoir le prix de thèse agroparistech
de l'association de recherche en
économie agroalimentaire ici en 2018
alors que ma thèse portait ni sur
l'économie lui sur l'agroalimentaire
alors qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans cette
thèse
pas grand chose pas grand chose de
révolutionnaire en tout cas premièrement
vous avez remarqué qu'on parle de plus
en plus de culinar it et enfin de
culinaires et pas de gastronomie il ya
une espèce de glissements sémantiques de
changement de vocables et c'est pas
anodin ce terme culinaire en fait il
montre qu'on est plutôt dans un dans une
ère de la cuisine d'auteur des produits
de qualité plutôt que dans l'image du
restaurant gastronomique avec des
produits nobles la nappe blanche les
couverts en métal argenté et où les
chichis et le tralala qui vont avec
alors c'est quoi cette culinary t il y
aurait quatre dimensions principales qui
sont la qualité la créativité et le
savoir-faire elle partage tout
positionnement confondues elle s'adresse
autant aux chefs de trois étoiles dans
son palace cas-là petites cantines de
rue
la quatrième dimension de la culinary tc
le partage et le partage il est crucial
aujourd'hui dans l'alimentation le
partage et nous amène à cette notion de
commensalité encore un mot barbare
commensalité ça vient du latin mensah la
table et dans tout comme le pain le
copain pardon partage son pain le
commensal partage sa table il a plutôt
intérêt à être sympathique donc vous
l'aurez compris ce qu'il faut retenir là
dedans c'est qu'au restaurant à la
maison on vient vivre des expériences
holistique globale où chaque élément est
comme un élément d'une mise en scène
d'une pièce de théâtre et doit être en
cohérence avec ses valeurs et avec ce
qu'il ya dans l'assiette
ensuite un autre élément sur lequel j'ai
travaillé c'est sur leurs agissements de
clients alors si vous avez fait un peu
de marketing ou au moins si vous avez
suivi une heure de cours de marketing
une fois dans votre vie on vous a parlé
du paradigme de confirmation des
attentes par digue de confirmation des
attentes c'est assez basique
j'ai des attentes si on y répond je suis
satisfait certes mais en fait satisfaire
quelqu'un ça sert pas à grand chose à
part ne pas leur après content
l'objectif c'est les ravir pour qu'ils
deviennent des ambassadeurs et donc est
ce qu'on fait on le satisfait certes au
départ et on rajoute un petit truc en
plus on rajoute quelque chose d'humain
quelque chose de personne
elle une émotion une surprise qui va
créer de l'enchantement et de la joie et
hop vous avez un client ravi ce client
ravi ça fait un citoyen heureux un
citoyen heureux il a envie de partager
son expérience et de la vivre avec vous
et ils vous ramènera peut-être
restaurant pourquoi s'en priver ce que
je voudrais partager avec vous c'est des
petites astuces pour créer des
expériences culinaires authentique qui
certes sont à la mode mais tant mieux et
qui permette du coup d'avoir un
marketing qui s'efface derrière
l'expérience cette envie et vient d'un
souvenir personnel de mon enfance ou
maman travaillant beaucoup parce qu'elle
était restauratrice aveu confiait
souvent maman de mes amis donc c'était
plutôt sympathique mais elle elle se
mettait un peu la pression et donc elle
allait faire un filet de saint-pierre
avec des haricots verts al dente et une
superbe un super beurre blanc c'était
délicieux certes mais en fait moi je le
rêvais d'un poulet patate du dimanche
faisons simple avec les alliés et
réfléchissons aux envies de nos clients
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire en
disette a premièrement refaites pas la
déco de a à z inspirez-vous de
l'existant sauvegarder le patrimoine
garder toutes les matières brutes le
bois le béton le vers le marbre
et même si ce n'est pas à la mode vous
verrez ça reviendra très vite à la mode
et vous serez content de l'avoir
conservé
ensuite faites vous plaisir à les
reporter les brocantes les vide greniers
acheter des meubles d'occasion la
vaisselle vintage
ce sera toujours différente chez le
voisin et puis créer du lien avec les
artisans votre territoire
elle est comment faire une commande
spéciale à un ébéniste un céramiste un
souffleur de verre
quatrièmement au lieu de vous ruiner
dans des roses venant de hollande
pourquoi pas aller faire un tour à la
campagne avec vos amis et ramener à un
bouquet de faire des gens c'est quand
même plus sympa et vous allez économiser
des sous
relocaliser votre alimentation manger
local et de saison n'hésitez pas à
végétaliser les plats et à revisiter les
classiques et puis à faire un chou-fleur
rôti comme on en voit dans beaucoup de
restaurants en ce moment ça coûte pas
cher on a toujours le plaisir de le
partager comme une belle pièce de jambes
les boissons chaudes
servez les dents des cafetières à piston
ou d'enlever dans des bocaux contenant
en verre salle et mettra en valeur
et puis ça ça vaut aussi pour le sucre
sp kg ce qui va avec
arrêtez avec les emballages individuels
puis franchement c'est pas compliqué de
faire plein de spéculoos et les garder
dans une boîte en métal cuisiner les
restes les parures les épluchures les
carcasses avec ça vous fait des
bouillons et des soupes
c'est rentable et ses sympathiques avec
le pain on pouvait faire des croûtons du
pain perdu et du pudding je vous assure
qu'un jour vous allez vous mettre à
aimer le pudding et puis s'il y avait
trois choses trois choses que vous
devriez faire vous même les pâtes à
tarte
la mayonnaise et la béchamel les
fondements de notre alimentation
française souvent fait avec trois
ingrédients trois fois rien qui coûtent
pas cher qui prennent peu de temps et
qui font toute la différence
c'est tellement dommage de jeter autant
de plastique et dépenser autant d'argent
dans les choses si simple à faire mettez
les saisons en bocal comme nos grands
mères le faisais confiture people's vous
aurez plus de complexes à servir des
tomates en hiver vous décorer les
étagères de vos cuisines et de salles de
restaurant et vous pourrez même vendre
vos bocaux pour apporter un peu de
l'expérience du restaurant à la maison
et finalement pas trop de marketing
évitez les enseignes à outrance les
opérations promotionnelles et trop
d'informations m'étais juste en scène
votre savoir faire avec des ustensiles
des bons produits
ça donnera envie de passer la porte
lorsque je voulais dire ce soir c'est
que c'est pas compliqué d'ouvrir un
restaurant ou de créer des univers il
faut être authentique
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir des chaises
designer d'avoir des millions d'euros à
investir et d'avoir un cv long comme le
bras
en voici vous commencez à son échelle
être authentique et laisser les choses
avancent et les unes après les autres
c'est ce qu'on appelle dans notre jargon
managériale l'effectuent à sion
alors je vous avais que vous ayez
quelque chose mon fonds de commerce à
moi c'est les tendances culinaires et
tendances culinaires par principe c'est
pas très durable alors comment en fait
vous voyez au coeur de ceux de 7,2 se
plonge tendance il ya un avocat de tous
ce qui a déjà mangé un avocat de toasts
ou toasts à la vodka pour ceux qui
maîtrisent pas trop le sujet ça fait un
peu de foudil gros paristech c'est bien
et qui a déjà envoyé une photo de son
avocat dos à ses amis possesseurs
instagram m'a pas moins de 10 millions
et demi de photos d'avocats d'autos sont
été publiés sur instagram vous imaginez
tout le temps passé par une autre
société a publié des photos de vos
cadeaux tox mais c'est vrai que c'est
bon l'avocat et nutritionnellement hyper
intéressant c'est joli c'est instagram
avec ses mails avocat ça pollue ça
pollue beaucoup ça c'est un graphique
issu d'une un article 2 du de
l'hebdomadaire allemand die zeit en 2017
qui nous parle de la consommation d'eau
pour la production d'un kilo de légumes
donc 180 litres d'eau pour une tomate
c'est déjà un bon score 150 litres pour
une salade et 1000 litres d'eau pour 1
kilo d'avocats mille litres d'eau quand
on sait que bah ça a tendance à être
produits dans les endroits où on risque
de manquer d'eau c'est à dire en afrique
du sud ou en amérique du sud que souvent
il a fallu déforester pour planter des
avocats et que s'est transportée par
container souvent frigorifié pendant 30
jours en bateau et quand c'est pas
transporté par avion
donc le résultat vous imaginez est
catastrophique alors on fait comment
parce que c'est quand même bon les
avocats d'automne
alors d'abord il existe des avocats
beaucoup plus fréquentable que d'autres
vous pouvez en trouver des corses
les marocains ont des portugais mais
coûte un peu plus cher donc on en mange
mais occasionnellement et le reste du
temps on se fait notre taux salavaux
karan ou en hiver avec des courge
butternut et puis en été avec des
tomates des aubergines confites à
l'huile d'olive et c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire ce soir c'est qu'en
tant qu expert du marketing culinaire je
mets
je milite pour un marketing culinaire
qui n'aurait plus de raison d'être le
marketing comme on connaît c'est fini
l'objectif c'est une création de valeur
pour les clients pour les salariés pour
les producteurs et les restaurateurs et
aussi pour les territoires je voudrais
ensemble qu'on mobilise notre énergie
pour re territorialisée notre
alimentation pour créer du lien entre
les acteurs des filières du manger pour
former les foot preneur de demain et
pour redonner vie à des territoires
comestibles bon maintenant je vous ai
donné l'eau à la bouche enfin je
l'espère je vous propose de continuer à
en discuter autour d'un café ou d'un
verre ou deux